on the side of the state this was the
key argument made by um uh uh ed
miliband today about this sort of
shocking 35 percent number back to the
1930s it's very keen to make that
argument i actually asked him a question
about this
and actually if you have a look at um
comparison so yes that's the
conservatives this is implied by the obr
numbers the sort of government's own
autumn statement numbers is 35
i try to work out myself actually if
they borrowed this amount 38
that's not an official number so not a
huge difference actually not not exactly
of course it's all about the size of the
state but when is the same it comes down
to it
not a huge difference exactly
all that but it's not just the size of
the state that uh
matters really there's other measures
too there's the uh
uh there's the obviously clearly on
deficit reduction uh there is a
difference
and on the face of it the difference is
that for the conservatives they'd be
cleared by 2018-19 for labor it be
cleared by 2020. but there's a really
important difference in that they
measure the deficit differently they
strip out capital spending on things
like you know trains and transport and
all that sort of stuff so this is
actually much kind of a much looser
fiscal straight jacket than that by as
much as 50 billion pounds but i do
expect those differences to kind of uh
you know emerge into the center ground
as the election uh battle in the
meantime because a lot of political
capital made out of that one can't you
but and when you look at the actually
how they're going to do that i mean
obviously all comes down to spending
cards in one way or another and there
are some differences there
well there are there are there are not
potentially that there are but what we
do know what they actually have actually
announced is sort of areas that they we
know that they're going to protect and
with the conservatives pretty clear
health uh flat in real terms but no cups
education overseas aids what we heard
pretty much from edmund this morning
health and overseas aid and a strong
hint that schools would be as well so
that's identically the same so the
difference is on that speed of of
achieving your deficit target that's
what makes the difference because
actually we think they're going to be
protecting pretty much the same areas
and on the other side of the equation
tax now we saw the headlines about uh
actually almost george was born stealing
the other side thunder when it came to
property taxes so to this degree they've
been very critical of the mansion tax
the conservatives but they did through
stamp duty was a tax on mansions now
this will only apply
when you sell a property this will apply
every year but it's much lower and
actually labor will do both so there is
there is a clear difference there on uh
on property uh on property taxation and
then lastly on personal taxation uh
another big difference labor will
reintroduce the 50 p tax rate for those
under more than 150 grand which uh of
course the conservatives got rid of a
couple of years ago but for
conservatives there's this 7.2 billion
pound tax allowance shift that's a 7.2
billion pound tax cut but the issue is
and what labor say is that that is
unfunded so there are some big
differences as well as some summaries
and lots of fighting over detail up
until the election a lot of that next
six months